i didn't expect to lose
one let alone or all three
you always think at least one will get
through
francis consalvas has just had to bury
his mother
father
and brother
they were unvaccinated
and all died with covid19
in the space of one week last month
his 40-year-old brother shawl
was the first to pass
his heart failed in the ambulance on the
way to the hospital
it's i can't even explain the feeling
um
after that i just honestly i felt like i
was the one that was dead
three days later his father basil died
francis managed to land in portugal
as his mother was rushed to hospital
when the eventually took me through
they clouded me up in ppe
took me through to the ward and
um
i realized
she was in a far worse state that they
were letting me know
and then at about quarter to eight i
received the phone call
there is nothing that can ever prepare
you for that
the funeral process was difficult
um
particularly when you're signing off for
three coffins
three sets of flower arrangements
and
you see that all coming down in three
different horses when you're at the
cemetery
francis says his family were against the
vaccine and have been misled by
conspiracies online
they were afraid they they had a lot of
um information that had been passed
through the internet and you can call it
misinformation i think it doesn't this
information is probably more appropriate
it's deliberately misleading people to
the point of it being propaganda and
if you don't trust the government if you
don't trust what you see on tv or social
media go to your doctor because they
will give you the best information you
have
in your mind how vital is it to have the
vaccine absolutely vital
if
they all had the vaccine i do believe i
would have at least one of them here
with me today
his unimaginable loss
a reminder that this virus is still
present
the memories
make it easier
because there were the good times there
were the happy times
you do miss those times
and there should have been more of them
dan whitehead sky news
in cardiff